do you feel successful
yes i mean like i'm very grateful too i
mean to be like a girl you know who came
from uh you know
yeah nothing a traumatic upbringing and
no money i dropped out of high school
to find success in what i do is like the
best feeling and inspire other young
women to be entrepreneurs is really sick
and also the trauma makes you [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] i would be a stale ass like
boring [ __ ] i think without the trauma
i
i wouldn't change it do you see a
therapist um i have i should now again i
don't know is it weird that i feel
weirdly okay but maybe that's just the
narcissism
i need but i should just in general it's
okay to feel honest with yourself you
know i'm somebody who's a proponent of
mental health coping skills i i've had
same i mean i understand that for sure
yeah so i have i have mental health
problems and and and i think everyone
has right but i come from a generation
where it wasn't really talked about yeah
or validated it wasn't validated and if
you can't get an x-ray of it means
nothing but i've been in therapy and my
kids are also i'm i'm you could speak
for yourself but she's like [ __ ] me up
no no i'm wishing i'm wishing there was
more trauma so i could be more
successful
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i don't know if this is a medical term
or not but after the first meeting he
diagnosed me as crazy is that possible
yeah that they would know somebody as
crazy well then start making content
well he needs he needs his shoes
does it take to go what do you look like
how do you date you
you don't if you are i am praying for
you that's where the religion comes in
um no but
no i mean i can definitely chill out
like i definitely have a side of me that
is just like you know the more normal
chill side my son is wait um i love you
you know i've known your son for like
five or six years i met him blacked out
drunk on a rooftop when i first before
him before i ever on his roof alex how
do you remember that oh at his apartment
yeah before i ever ever ever had moved
here did you need planned parenthood you
hung out i did not need that
um no but wait you blacked out at alex's
apartment on his roof i did alex sorry
no that's so alex though a lot of my
friends were there as well he wasn't it
wasn't it was just like you want to hear
something funny because i always say
like
he's got the coolest place yeah i know
right did you did you cash out on that
one no no that's alex
anyway he's got he's got the coolest
place i start hitting on him i'm like
but and the thing is that he's got this
rooftop and you can go and sometimes i'm
walking around and i'll just say santa
monica i'm walking around santa monica
with my wife and i'll go you know what
let's just sit maybe we can ask alex if
he's home we could sit on the rooftop so
cute isn't it nice
he says no and he always says no no and
he says no there's people and now i
imagine every time he says no that
there's people like you up there passed
out but maybe that's why he's saying no
to simply protect you from who is there
well he tells me there are people that
just don't want tan lines yeah oh that's
a really good way of putting it um it
wasn't it wasn't serving me brothel when
i was there it was really serving me
like nice wholesome home and it was that
is fun that is what that's alex actually
if i remember right though there is a
lot of crazy stuff and like a secret
bookshelf that like takes you into
another room is that yours
i'm not sure why he has that going on he
showed you his secret shelf
isn't it narnia you call it narnia right
right i love narnia no i didn't do
anything bad at me
no no unprotected sex no drugs nothing
crazy we just hung out am i a nice toy
am i another grandparent
[Music]